you have mentioned that the script is
inspired on real events real experiences
but also there's fiction you call it out
of fiction how do you blend the two as
you were writing this story yeah well in
the movie appears the mother the old
mother of the characters and Antonio
character she said that she doesn't like
out of fiction but it's a kind of joke
because you know for these kind of
ladies rural rural ladies that she
shouldn't know what out of vision is but
so it was a kind of joke
but but it's true I mean it's impossible
to denied that the movie is aspiring
myself and that I was the reference for
Antonio's character and so I mean there
is many many sequins are basic in real I
mean in real in my rural experience but
but you know in every time since the
beginning everything is mixed with
fiction so I would I when I when I say
that in this movie because that's true
represents me a lot above all very
intimately it means that I made mine the
memory is not only my memories the
memories of my family the memories of my
brother the memories of the people that
were surrounding me in the eighties or
the people with who I was living in the
60s so I mean for a simple one one
sequence one sequence comes from reality
I mean that when the mother asked him if
he remembered how how she wanted to be
dressed traveling yeah so I mean I
remember that but it was my mother
didn't ask myself to that question I
mean she asked it to my sister because
this you know I mean I mean this kind of
she'll chew off deaf which is very deep
very intense and very colorful too in la
mancha this is a female tradition so I
made it mine and also I was really moved
when I was with when I was shooting the
sequence but I was stolen the memories
of my sister
Antonia can you tell us how you tackled
this character and how were the
conversations between you and Pedro in
the creation of some other Maya
it was not just created in a unique way
there were many different things that
happened during the process of making
this movie the process of rehearsing and
even things that happened even before I
read the script and you know in reality
have been saying this and it's kind of
difficult to explain but I'll try in
reality I start creating this character
nine years ago when we did the skinny 11
because for 22 years we didn't work
together I came back to Spain didn't do
too much Spanish movies particularly
none in those two decades and I came
from Hollywood with my experiences and I
just through all those experiences on
the table and said this is what I have
learned this is what I am now this is
the voice that I can use this is this is
that this is this is not and this after
a week rehearsing with Pedro Romero he
said to me you know all of those things
that you have learned there they are not
very useful for my type of movies
and and so I at that time you know I I
thought I went that's not nice you know
I mean I'm bringing all of these things
to the table incident so I can't not
confronted him because we're friends you
know and every time even moments of
tensions that you know in creative
processes they always are moments of
tension we always respect ourselves and
you know as friends and stuff like that
but it was a tense shooting you know
thing I saw the movie in the Toronto
Film Festival and I realized he managed
to take out of me a character that I
didn't even know I had inside and I was
a big lesson for me and and and when and
things neither happened you have to be
humble and so I wanted to work with him
again because I wanted to go to him in a
completely different disposition and he
happens you know 90s after he calmly
says I just wrote this thing you you're
gonna find a lot of references to our
life together to the 80s and number of
things you know and I said to him at the
point flat I said listen I if there was
some metals that I just put on myself
I'm gonna take them out I'm gonna be a
plain soldier I want to listen and when
I open my eyes and my ears I don't want
to use the tools that I have been using
for many years I want to start from the
scratch many things happen in the last
two years one of them is that I had a
heart attack
I changed slightly the way that I was
perceiving reality I guess and and he
saw that because he said that to me at
some point during the rehearse I said
there is something that has changed in
you and I want you to use it I knew
exactly what he was talking about you
know when you see if the face of death
very close to you
there are a lot of things that change in
your life you know and I saw you know my
acting also going to a completely
different way and and I have this
opportunity through this character to
express myself differently to anything
the first thing that came to my mind I
was just to metaphorically kill Antonio
at least the image of the type of
characters that I was doing until that
point and it was a perfect opportunity
to just step in and completely new
universe then there were another amount
of things that happened there was a lot
of emotional information which is very
difficult to explain but it's something
that you don't count on it when you
actually start the process
it just happened there are certain
scenes in the movie that I didn't plan
to do like that but then his information
his emotional information because he's
so attached to this character to his own
story to reconciliation to coming to
terms with your life and your past it
was so emotional that you know it in a
way it was giving me that emotional
information that was not written
anywhere Alberto you mentioned that
unlike other filmmakers Pedro doesn't
give you a guide track and that you have
to start from scratch when you start
composing can you elaborate on that yeah
good evening yes is a incredible
experience to start a movie and having
but the voices of the actors and at that
moment is the the inspiration for me how
they speak how they are telling the
story and less by less with Pedro
together we choose for what and why we
need the music and it's film we have the
this first question very present this
time I try I try to convince Pedro that
the film doesn't need music because I
saw that I watch the movie and I for me
was complete and I don't know I didn't
know how to do something in that
intimacy how to to be there with and
make the music so transparent
and unconnected with the meaning and
that was my my god the connection not to
make an embellishment to make beautiful
music but to to connect with the meaning
and with the soul of of everything and I
had Pedro beside me each each Sunday
coming to to harm to my studio and
saying oh that's that is okay why don't
go for this other side so we divided the
filming in different elements musical
elements one of one of them is
effectively electronic and probably is
the music that explores the dark side of
of Salvador I don't know why electronic
in some moments can convey reality more
than the the beauty full of strings and
that are more connected with the Unreal
and for us was very important to have
this other material material in the in
the electronic portion and translated us
today to to his interior thank you
[Applause]